andré pousse on vous avez coureur
cycliste
on vous savez également acteur mais là
je vous découvre derrière un bar en
train de se préparer des cocktails dans
un restaurant qui est le vôtre
apparemment c'est une attentiste avant
on nous ya les années maintenant je fais
ça je suis enfin je fais passer à tout
le temps je fais ça tu temps en temps
quand je reçois des amis de l'est
derrière le vert ou même aux fourneaux
savary mois sourd alors parmi ses amis
dont vous me parliez tout à l'heure ce
qui à alphonse boudard
je pense qu'il faut se méfier vieux
camarade way connu comment vous l'aï
pris comme modèle quand vous tourner des
films de gangsters et alors j'espère
surtout qu'on ne rejoint au pas du tout
parce que la france était un voleur et
moi je joue les assassins alors ce
serait vraiment hostile c'est plutôt
comme a dit marquante a dit forcément tu
peux pas jouer autre chose a une tête à
deux mandats d'arrêt mais alphonse tirez
pas moi je suis tout le temps en paye
pour sa cliente eu aussi du reste
alors lorsque vous êtes avec
alphonse boudard ce que et quand y'a des
caves comme ça autour de vous ce que
vous parlez argo il ya très peu de gens
qui parlent vrai art goyave et audiard
qui parlait havrais argot et qui
n'écrivait pas vraiment en argot
contrairement à tout ce qu'on a pu dire
lorsqu'il disait toujours méfiez vous il
est méfiez vous parce qu'à valenciennes
ils vont pas comprendre et il avait
raison il ya des mots d'argot keane
largo en fait largo c'est le patois des
parisiens largo c'est vrai c'est un peu
sa salle à l'argot s'était fait
évidemment c'était fait pour que l'écart
ne comprennent pas elle encore pelé les
voyous ont vu que les cavs comprenez ils
ont ils ont multiplié la difficulté en
parlant verlan et plan l'état pu les
dépouilles arrive les gens croient que
j'ai parlé en français se dit tiens j'ai
pas bien compris ils entendent pas des
mots d'argot j'avais d'un plan qu'elle
ait pu écouler arrivent alors
mitterrand d'ailleurs il était chez
branle autrefois il était bléquin avec
morose ivre et tout le monde y vient
oui alors cette amitié lagoutte
définissiez comme viril comme
durable et tout ça pour entre vous et
les bouddhas parce que c'est pas un des
héritages du milieu c'est pas une des
traditions de milieux corps est conservé
boudard c'est les voyous de la vieille
école il y avait des principes de base
et il ya encore des gens comme ça du
reste dans le milieu mais ce qu'il ya
c'est qu'ils retour il ya tellement de
de crasse que c'est pas tous comme ça
mais les vieux principe c'était on
touche pas aux vieillards en tout je
pense aux enfants abaissement la femme
de ses amis et on tue pas pour de
l'argent du pont se défendre c'était la
base ça et alphonse il a toujours
respecté ces idées là même si c'est pas
un tueur je veux dire que l'idée de base
de sa cessé de déverser sa de l'ancienne
école alors quand boudard vient ici vous
j'imagine que vous mettez aux fourneaux
ah oui je vais préparer croire général
blanquette de veau cassoulet c'est ce
que je fais
et bien tout ça ça valait dans la
blanquette